What's happened is tragically. We had created a tremendous segregation.
Yeah, well, a new underclass, if you will, uh, an immigrant's underclass,
which Sweden never had, and we don't know how to deal with it. Um,
we're also running out of money because we have the most expensive welfare
system in the world, and now we're trying to deal with it.
Nobody knows what to do.
Can you guys explain a little bit about how the immigration
issue arose that basically this all started just in the last really seven
years, something like that,
that a pretty much homogenous society for better or worse
decided I think, but correct me if I'm wrong.
I think probably with good intentions by people that weren't thinking that much
to bring in a ton of people.
How many immigrants roughly have come in over the last half decade or so.
Or if you take it over a decade, um,
the numbers are always changing because they're playing around with them.
So it depends on how you kind of calculate it, but it is,
it is a bit over a million.
So, okay. So roughly a 10th of the population came in,
let's say in the last decade from these countries, um,
what do you think the leaders thought exactly was going to happen?
Let's say well-intentioned but do you think maybe I'm giving them too much?
No, no.
Let's let's do the well intention because I like to give people the benefit of
the doubt. Yeah.
I think they were hoping for a multicultural nearby now with,
you know, kebabs, you know, and some belly dancing. Yeah.
And a lot of smoked fish. You guys are killing it in the smoked fish game,
by the way, eat some delicious out of that is true.
Yeah. But other than that,
I think the idea is if you live in a culture that is so
homogenous as Sweden is you cannot think outside the box of our own culture.
They don't even perceive that we have a culture.
They probably believe they will become suites very quickly when they
realize how right and good we are.
Yes, they will. Didn't happen.
Cool. Yeah. So if we were not to give them the benefit of the doubt,
because I also,
I try not to go to people's motives and I think the road to hell is paved with
good intentions.
And I think a lot of these people think they're doing the right thing, but,
but let's go to the non good motive part.
I think you just wrote a book about it. I mean, what,
what do you think these people thought they were doing?
Or what do you think they thought was going to happen just when you change
demographics that much a 10th of a population is a huge, huge, huge amount.
Well, I think they wanted to him.
So the social Democrat came into power. Uh,
they actually lifted up the working class to a, a much better living standard.
And the idea was, as soon as we get them up to middle-class living standards,
they will become true communists and understand that they need to devote
everything to the struggle.
What happened in reality was that they were perfectly fine with their flat
screen TVs. They wanted more flat-screen TVs and longer vacation time.
They didn't want to join a communist revolution. They became in essence, uh,
well, our equivalent of Republicans, I suppose.
So they needed new voters in a sense. And they invoked.
And then they took in a lot of people into the most over-regulated labor market
in the world. And these people,
second generation and third generation immigrants.
They're not getting into the system. They're keeping them, uh, for the ballots.
They want their votes and they, and they keep them on subsidies. Um,
some of these kids,
they see that the system is rigged against them and they have no choice.
They will, of course they will become gangsters.
They will go off and fight for ISIS after a while. Not all of them, obviously.
It gets important that at this point to remember that the people that
came in, you know, those individuals,
it's not their fault inherent.
They weren't invited. Well,
that's why I asked about the intentions and good or bad of the people that
brought them in. Not.
No, I like to think, you know, crowds always go crazy. Um,
but individuals are much more reasonable. You know, somebody has, you know,
fleeing a war or, you know, I have the deepest sympathy. Yes,
of course I would do the same thing, but it is irresponsible.
If you have a so regulated labor market and you,
you take in more people than you can help. It.
That's just like you were throwing a party that goes haywire on Facebook.
Everyone was invited, uh, you know, I have drinks where 12 people.
W what, what did they think that people were going to do? Like,
what kind of jobs did they think people were going to have?
Or did they immediately say you're taking care of for a year? You know,
we hear these stories out of German.
Government wants to start a camel farm in Gothenburg.
That was one of the one experiment for some. And that's, uh, yeah,
that was crazy. Um, that actually sort of racing and sort of racist,
but no, we can't give you a proper job, but we'll give you some,
sub-studies start to camel farm. You shouldn't be good at that.
And also we have plenty of cameras in Sweden. No, we don't truly,
the people come in. And as you said, they're often fleeing war.
You have sympathies with all these people. The government then says,
here's some stuff, but you can't be forever.
Although they sort of do have it forever,
but not just that you can't have it forever. It's a limited amount of stuff.
Right. We can't put you and then, then they can turn around and say, see,
we're also racist because we didn't make you millionaires at night one.
And exactly, they get a flat, they get a, a minimum, uh,
uh, living subsidy subsidy, uh, but, and then, uh,
they are expected to vote left. And that is what it looks like.
If you break down the statistics of different municipalities and how they
vote. I mean, in the roofs, in Guatemala,
it was like eight 70 to 90% worth it for the social Democrats or the lefts.
Yes. Yes. I mean, there, there, you know, we have the numbers for all of that,
but what what's happened is tragically.
We had created a tremendous segregation. Yeah. Well, a new underclass,
if you will, uh, an immigrant's underclass, which Sweden never,
and we don't know how to deal with it.
And we're also running out of money because we have the most expensive welfare
system in the world. And now we're trying to deal with it. Nobody knows what to.
Th this is, uh, sort of dangerous question in a way,
but I think these conversations always end up here, which is,
do you think in a weird way, this then breeds racism? Yes. That,
that good intentioned people, right? You, I mean, you just made it very clear.
You have no ill will towards these people,
but then these people come into these countries. They're given these things,
they demand more,
the politicians use them for votes and then good people who are not racist,
but maybe don't have a lot of time to think about all these things suddenly
start becoming kind of racist. It's just, it's just a sad fact that humanity.
Absolutely. And I think it goes both ways. I think the Swedes wanted to invite,
uh,
poor people from the third world to come and live in Sweden because they wanted
to feel good themselves. But, uh,
also they thought everyone would want to become Swedish, of course.
But then they get a lot of immigrants and the immigrants look at the Swedish
society and they're like, well, maybe I'm,
I'm going to keep some of my own culture because I don't think this is so great.
And if you were to sort of,
and also if you keep them out of the system and you never left them in and you
stick them in ghettos, uh, of course they will start to hit you.
And there's a weird thing that I think Europe has that America doesn't have,
which is that if you were to assimilate them more sort of push more of a Swedish
culture on them, that would be against Swedish nature in a bizarre way.
We're America. We have a melting pot here.
So come here with all of your traditions and all of those things,
but mix into the fabric of America where Europe has more of a
ghettoization, okay.
This, I think the recent America can,
can do this better is because your country is founded on the principle of
individuality and individuals.
Whereas Sweden is founded on the idea of collectivism and that
makes it really hard to break the molds. Now I have a good friend.
Who's he's work. He's doing a lot of work with newly arrived, uh,
African boys. And like the top question. This is most often Shiri. The,
the question he is most often asked by these guys is like,
how do I make Swedish friends? I don't know. They never open up.
I'm never in touch with them. And at the same time, I mean, this is like, again,
bringing tears to my eyes. They want to work.
They want to break into becoming useful. Uh, at the same time,
suites will be telling you, Oh no, how, how you should behave. No,
I couldn't possibly tell you just be, be yourself.
And by they give nothing away because they don't understand being so
collectivist. Like we have a very closed, very complicated culture.
And if we want to invite people into our culture, we need to start, you know,
you're here, we do it this way. This is, you know, but that is considered,
um, almost racist, certainly socially aggressive to tell people that,
well, this is how we do things around here. We take off.
Our shoes before we call them coming. Someone's home. That is quite unique.
Yeah. Yeah. It's, I'll send the Japanese,
although we're more sloppy than the Japanese, I think, uh,
because there are unwritten rules. Of course there are,
but for the longest time,
Swedes denied that because it would be racist to admit we had our own culture.
Can you guys talk a little bit about how,
how you differentiate from some of the other Nordic countries?
Because as I said, we always point to the Nordic countries,
but Sweden is the one that we really focus on. Um,
but it sounds from what I could tell,
and I did visit Denmark and I visited Finland and, uh, at a couple other places,
um, Denmark doesn't seem to have the problems as much.
As well. They did up until they had those cartoonists scandals.
And then they sort of understood what it was all about.
If you can't criticize Mohammed,
that's basically blasphemy laws and no modern Western state would stand for
that.
Looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about international issues
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our international playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.